gilles emmanuel jaquet bonjour
bonjour alors merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
alors l'iran s'était satisfait de la
prise de pouvoir des talibans mais a
critiqué hier la formation du nouveau
gouvernement comment le comprendre pour
quelles raisons
eh bien les talibans et le gouvernement
iranien n'ont pas historiquement une
bonne relation en fait dans les années
90 dans l'ouest de l'afghanistan du
personnel consulaire iraniens avaient
été exécutés par les talibans et ça
avait été une un élément de discorde
entre les deux régimes maintenant
l'élément le plus évident aussi derrière
et de nature religieuse les talibans
sont des fondamentaux fondamentalistes
pardon sunnites alors que les iraniens
sont chics et on sait dans le passé les
talibans ont persécuté en afghanistan
les membres de la minorité chiite hazara
ce sont un peu les éléments qui
expliquent ce méfiance qu'on a aussi un
terrain vis-à-vis du nouveau
gouvernement établit à kaboul téhéran
qui déplore le manque de
représentativité ethnique c'est à peu
près ce que déplore aussi toutes les
chancelleries occidentales
qu'en pensez vous l'iran défend aussi
cette pluralité
oui alors l'iran d'ailleurs ou
information l'iran est un pays qui est
quand même multi ethnique dans les
iraniens vous avez des gens de
différentes régions des véhicules sûrs
d'eux des lourds y
alors de ce point de vue on peut dire la
lyre on voit le nouveau gouvernement en
afghanistan aussi comme un gouvernement
uniquement finalement pachtoune et les
gouvernements occidentaux
de même qu'ils appellent à l'inclusivité
qui souhaitent voir un gouvernement
représenter la diversité d'afghanistan
et bien ils sont déçus puisque dans ce
armement on a pour l'instant du seul
personne qui n'est pas parce toons et le
vice-premier ministre le mollah abdul
salam hanafi qui est d'origine ouzbèke
et pour les femmes oui pardon pour leur
est familier encore rien d'annoncé il ya
des personnalités politiques féminine
afghane comme favoris à koffi shukria
barakzaï qui n'ont pas été invités lors
n'ont pas été invoqués anthony évoqué en
tout et en public
les deux pays qui ont des similitudes
géographique et culturel puisqu'il n'ya
9 121 km de frontière commune avec une
langue le dari qui est proche du du
pachtounistan
qui sont réfugiés en iran après les
vagues de départ successives c'est ce
genre de relation aussi qui rapproche
ces les deux pays
alors le dari ont été proches en fait du
persan ce sont le dari est un peu là
variantes dialectales qu'on en
afghanistan.le bashung est à part ces
langues indo-européennes comme les
autres mais il est bien à part de ces du
baril du persan maintenant il ya
effectivement dans l'histoire de la
perse
différents empire perse qui se sont
succédé au cours de l'histoire ont vu
leur territoire cet angle sur
l'afghanistan qui lie à l'histoire il ya
aussi une personne il ya des références
comme le livre des rois et d'autres
mythes personnes qui sont
partagées par les ardents et il est vrai
il ya cette frontière commune et aussi
les vrais des millions de réfugiés
afghans qui sont en iran depuis plus de
20 ans est ce que finalement téhéran ne
ménage pas aussi ses intérêts avait avec
le nouveau gouvernement le nouveau
pouvoir rarement on pense notamment à
l'eau ou au pétrole
tout à fait alors il ya des problèmes
bilatéraux entre les deux pays notamment
sur la gestion de l'eau dans l'ouest de
l'afghanistan et dans l'est de l'iran il
ya aussi des questions commerciales
puisque vous avez une route commerciale
qui passe de l'iran à l'afghanistan vous
avez des des comment dire des relations
commerciales entre les deux pays et le
changement de pouvoir qui s'est produit
à kaboul a mené une période chaotique
qui est un peu aussi déstabilisé ces
échanges aussi il ya effectivement vous
l'avez mentionné la question énergétique
l'iran est un pays producteur de pétrole
et gaz et l'afghanistan elle ne produit
pas ses ressources elle en a au
contraire normes aimant besoin et puis
plus généralement peut-être on voit une
forme c'est-à-dire de sagesse de la part
du gouvernement à téhéran qui cherche à
avoir des relations on pourrait dire
apaisée avec ses voisins afghans mais
adhérents restent méfiants et on
souhaite de voir quelles vont être les
actions entreprises par le gouvernement
le nouveau gouvernement de kaboul
téhéran qui a qui a maintenu des
relations avec les talibans s quel rôle
est ce que le système en l'iran pourrait
jouer un rôle dans la médiation avec
avec l'afghanistan d'aujourd'hui
l'iran pourrait mais il faudrait voir
qu'ils souhaitent associer l'iran cette
médiation si on parle de pays
occidentaux
les états unis je les vois mal demander
ça vire alors qu'eux ils ont une
négociation devrait relancer sur la
question du nucléaire avec l'iran sur
les sanctions et cela ne se peut pas les
pays européens et barres chromées moins
de mal à mon avis
comment dire coopérer avec mirande sur
cette question là d'autant plus qu'il ne
faut pas perdre de vue que au cours de
plusieurs crises au moyen-orient
l'iran s'est souvent montré assez
conciliante envers les pays occidentaux
on pourrait rappeler par exemple la
butte aux potaches dans laquelle
les iraniens ont été finalement les
alliés des pays occidentaux merci
beaucoup gilles emmanuel jacquet pour
votre éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes chargé de cours en relations
internationales analyste à l'institut
international de recherche pour la paix
à genève